Monday morning after months of design
and testing installation of the curtain
wall finally began in d2o
their goal for today is to hang a dozen
panels okay here's the thing you guys
better get harnessed up
does this cables coming down so if you
want to get underneath this at all reven
you gotta be a deck Foreman Brian Oliver
oversees the crew doing the actual
installation today he has no lack of
bosses over him is general Foreman Paul
Truex over him his supervisor Rick
Morris over all of them is the
surprisingly low-key Tim Walz wig today
on this job it's getting everybody in
tune with what's going on because he's
got all new guy like the rest of the
construction world everybody's so busy
helps really hard
Hey
lousy Smokies now yelling well soon as
this gets poured away we're on this is
right where we're gonna start we got to
be careful with this stuff we're gonna
hear my 11 o'clock they've got things
sorted out enough to begin attaching the
first panel
well for the time being
once Brian gets the panel into position
he realizes that the steel t-bar it
mounts to is an inch too long this units
got to come out that's as far as we can
go we have a condition here the bottoms
got to come in we know we got to trim
the length okay but that's only gonna
let us come in what about another inch
that means we got to trim that leg off
cut beyond there steel key clip out an
inch okay okay
the unit's got to come in an inch and 13
and you're hard up against there no what
I am is it's the length of the T clip I
can whack that length off that's not a
problem I've got to figure out a way to
get the T clip back inside or I got a
whack the aluminum clip hey torch
once the tea bars are trimmed brian
discovers another problem this time with
the concrete slab the floor is not
perfectly plumb so it's kicked out a
little bit so while we're doing this
we're putting it backward long lacking
shims Brian improvises using the steel
bands that the shipping crates came
wrapped in
holdin me bumping cut you loose clamp on
it I'm gonna give you another shot
anyway you know that
that's good let's do it
their goal was to hang 12 for 1 in it
let's go home by the end of the day
they've hung 2 with 3423 still to go